konkretes ziel für stephen hawkings
projekt stephen hawking bereichert die
wissenschaft mit seinen arbeiten seine
hypothesen oder auch anderen beiträgen
die die wellen schlagen und somit zum
nachdenken anregen auch bei seinem
neuesten projekt geht es um eine
spannende sache aber zunächst einmal
stephen hawking stephen hawking ist
einer der berühmtesten physiker unserer
zeit und hat unter anderem durch seine
thesen zu schwarzen löchern für aufsehen
gesorgt wenn er also etwas
veröffentlicht dann hat das also richtig
gewicht und im jahr 1974 hatte der
astrophysiker beispielsweise gezeigt
dass ein schwarzes loch nicht nur
absolviert sondern auch reflektiert
obwohl grundsätzlich nicht einmal licht
aus einem schwarzen loch gelangen kann
ist einer besonderen sehr schwachen
strahlung möglich aus einem schwarzen
loch zu entkommen konkret belegen oder
nachweisen konnte man die strahlung
aufgrund der schwäche jedoch erst im
august diesen jahres da konnte der
israelische physiker chef steinhauer
einen ersten ernstzunehmenden beweis für
hawking strahlung finden
steven hawking hat nicht nur thesen wie
die zu den schwarzen löchern in die welt
gesetzt manchmal sorgt er auch für
aufruhr mit weniger positiven aussagen
er warnte unter anderem vor einem
kollaps unseres universums als grund
dafür sieht er die auswirkung der
forschung am higgs boson vor rund fünf
jahren gelangen genf der erste nachweis
wird das teilchen das allen
existierenden die masse verleiht das ist
auch als higgs-teilchen bekannt für den
deckung nach knapp 50 jahren
forschungsarbeit gab es für die
verantwortlichen wissenschaftler sogar
den nobelpreis für physik
und was ist an den teichen jetzt so
besorgniserregend
unter extremen stressbedingungen
verursacht durch ein
teilchenbeschleuniger könnte das teil
einen katastrophalen vakuum abfall
bewirken
bislang gibt es aber noch keinen
teilchenbeschleuniger in dem ein solches
fatales experiment durchgeführt werden
könnte meinte der professor gegenüber
der sunday times und jetzt zur hot wings
neuesten streich unter dem namen
breakthrough start lief im april diesen
jahres ein projekt der breakthrough
initiative sun
dabei sind leute wie eben die mobbing
aber auch mark zuckerberg militär juri
milner und der ehemalige chef des ames
research centers der nasa pete worden
gemeinsam wollen sie
einzige und extrem schnelle raumschiffe
entwickeln die raumschiffe sollen nur
mit dem nötigsten ausgestattet sein
und wo sollen aus mauern bestehen wafer
sind runde nur wenige millimeter dicke
scheiben aus silizium
dazu kommt noch ein sonnensegel mit dem
sonnensegel spart man sich nämlich
jegliche große antriebstechnologie
raumschiffe mit sonnensegeln können von
der erde aus also von uns aus mit dem
nötigen schub versorgt werden mehrere
laser werden dafür auf die raumschiffe
gerichtet um sie in minutenschnelle auf
20 prozent der lichtgeschwindigkeit zu
beschleunigen
durch die leichtbauweise können die
raumschiffe strecken in wenigen stunden
oder wenigen tagen zurücklegen für die
andere weltraum gefährte wie satelliten
zum beispiel mehrere monate brauchen
würden das universum ist da doch also
viel leichter und vor allem schneller
erkundbar und jetzt bekommt auch noch
ein anderes projekt der breakthrough
initiative ein konkretes ziel das
mysterium um kec 846 2852 oder auch baby
star genannt baby star soll mit hilfe
der instrumente des breakthrough listen
projektes aufgeklärt werden das
mysterium tammy starr bereitet forschern
seit jahren kopfzerbrechen nämlich immer
wieder unterschiedlich stark und dann
wieder schwach auf die ursache dafür ist
noch immer unbekannt in berkley
versuchen forscher in nächster zeit mit
dem radioteleskop des greenback
observatoriums ein petabyte an daten zu
sammeln mit diesen ersten erkenntnissen
über tammy starr und sein ungewöhnliches
leuchten soll für hawkings projekte
vorarbeit geleistet werden bevor das
rätsel um den stern gelöst wird gibt es
natürlich schon erste wenn auch etwas
abwegige spekulation
manche wie jason wright vermuten dass
intelligente außerirdische lebensformen
um den stern herum ein gerüst gebaut
haben um dessen energie nutzen zu können
es gibt auch schon stimmen zum möglichen
kontakt mit aliens denn word immer vom
berkley city research center hält das
zusammentreffen zwar für
unwahrscheinlich sagte aber zitat es
wird etwas bizarres sein dass jemand
durch einen zufall findet etwas das
niemand erwartet hat und auf das wir
dann genauer gucken und sagen hey das
ist eine zivilisation zitat
wenn euch das video gefallen hat dann
lassen wir gerne einen daumen nach oben
und ein kostenloses abo da darf einfach
hier klicken und wenn ihr hier klickt
kommt jetzt zu einem video in dem wir
uns noch genauer mit der hawking
strahlung beschäftigen
viel spaß dabei und was glaubt ihr was
bzw
vielleicht sogar wer sorgt für die
helligkeitsschwankungen bei teenie-star
lass mir eure meinung dazu gerne in den
kommentaren
und bis dahin eine schöne woche